trump is a strategist trump is not uh
yeah he's he's not at your level of uh
his his method of getting things done is
very different than the way you get it
done and and to my point though his
people betrayed him the first time and
he hasn't learned yet and i pray at
night that going into this next election
cycle he will have a change of heart and
mind because his people
betrayed him when you think strategy too
much sometimes
you're too smart for your own good yeah
but people so so then what jesus was uh
not the his people betrayed him yes so
that that is part of the game the part
of the game is
betrayal betrayal is part of the level
you're competing at
you you're not going to be able to uh uh
stop betrayal no man it happens that the
higher you move up the more it's gonna
hurt but it's gonna happen no doubt so
he's he's playing at a different level
and it's very normal for that i i
understand the way i'm explaining it
doesn't make sense like what do you mean
it's supposed to be normal it's very
normal at that level